I love how candid both of you guys are
about your personal struggles as far as
depression and be in your addiction path
dealing with Demi Lovato and the recent
news of her what words of wisdom do you
have for someone who is going to
overcome that I mean I married an addict
who is has almost 14 years and it is
it's a daily struggle and it will always
be a daily struggle I don't know that I
have words of wisdom because I have not
been there but I I have the wisdom to
say we're here for you and it's gonna be
a struggle and I'm really sorry that you
were dealt that deck yeah absolutely but
it takes someone who knows and it's
worked a little bit somebody told me a
long time ago a pretty a pretty smart
guy said any kind of addiction is really
the result of unresolved grief and that
has held true for me as I've gone
through life ever since and that's why I
give that piece of advice my mother in
law also sent to me and whatever choices
you made yesterday were those choices in
today is a new day and they're all new
choices and you can choose again and you
can live a great life you can live
whatever kind of life you want to live
you can be straight for 20 years or you
can like still enjoy your life the way
you want to you can be the author of the
kind of life you want to live no matter
what your addictions or your
peculiarities are you know and you can
you can master anything you wish to
master with faith and with support